So to start with, you'll notice that the scene here
is quite overcast blue.
And a big reason for that is, right now, we
are not taking advantage of our volumetric fog.
We are simply just using our Rayleigh scattering,
atmosphere scattering, and just a general fog.
So to change that, it's really simple.
Let's just go into our exponential height fog
and check volumetric fog.
Now, I'm going to just close our environment light mixer
for a second to show you that the environment light
mixer is simply just a tool that's
interfacing on top of all the other things
that we're normally used to.
So for example, if I click my exponential height fog,
go over to my Details panel, you notice here
that volumetric fog is checked.
That's simply all our environment light mixer
is doing is just toggling that.
So if I go to our exponential height fog, turn it off.
See down here, it's off.
All right, so we'll keep everything else as default,
not the point of this section.
We'll go in, we'll tweak it later as need be.
One other shortcut that will help out
a lot with adjusting your lighting
is if you press Control-L, you'll get this little gizmo.
And I just move my mouse around.
So I'm not clicking anything on the mouse.
I'm just simply holding Control-L.
This is going to allow me to move the directional light
in our scene.
And because we use the environment light mixer
to start with, all of our other components
are essentially linked together in the background.
So if I did something like kind of zoom up here
so we can see outside of our scene, that's super blown out.
We'll go back in.
But if I hold Control-L and kind of move this down
to do like a sunset, you'll start
to see that the coloration of the sky and the sun
kind of changes to more of like a sunset or sunrise.
So hold down Control-L and adjust your settings
and just get something that looks good.
Kind of put it here.
And we are good to go.
So now what I want to do is just adjust some of our height
fog to show you the different settings and parameters
that you'll commonly use when
needing to adjust it to whatever visual style
that you want.
So the first setting that we're going to do,
so this is in our exponential height fog.
Again, we have volumetric fog checked, is our fog density.
And that is exactly what it sounds like.
Now, at the course of as we're building these things,
you're unsure of what a parameter does.
Just simply highlight over it.
So just leave your mouse over there for about a second.
And it will pop up a little contextual helper
to essentially tell you what that parameter does.
So fog density is exactly what it sounds like.
So you can see I can take this up and get more fog.
Now, you'll notice that as I'm left click dragging this,
it stops at 0.05.
You absolutely can take this above that by simply clicking.
And let's do something like 0.5, go crazy.
And you see we get a lot more fog within our scene.
So if you just click drag, you
see that you can do that, left click,
and type in whatever you want.
So I'll do something like 0.25 just
to show this height fog fall off.
Now, it's going to be a little hard to see within our scene
here, but this is essentially how far vertically
your height will be viewed.
So you can adjust this up or down
if you want the fog to be more of a whole scene
or just isolated to something like a low laying fog.
You'll adjust your fog height fall off.
Now, we do have secondary fog data.
And this essentially is just an extra layer
on top of our fog to allow for some more artistic control.
So for example, we could set our fog density, fog height
fall off to something kind of low like a low fog,
kind of a ground fog, make it super dense,
and then use our secondary fog, which the properties are
essentially the exact same, to do something
more like an atmospheric fog.
So that density would be lower.
The height fall off, we'd obviously
want it to be able to go higher within our scene.
And then height offset, we could just
raise that a little bit again to not compete
with our low lying fog.
Now, this may be a little bit difficult for us to see here,
but fog in scattering color, I will just click this.
And I'll do something like a hot pink
show you just so we can kind of preview it.
So you can see that this will change the in scattering color.
Now, be careful with this property,
because we can also change the in scattering
with our sky atmosphere, in particular with the Rayleigh.
But know that you can individually control this,
which is great if you're trying to do some pretty
cool artistic effects.
All right.
Start distance and end distance, we're going to leave at 0.
And that just essentially sets it at infinity.
But if performance is a consideration
or you're trying to just eke out a few more frame time,
then by adjusting these, you can specify
where the fog is viewed, both again from the in distance
and the start distance.
I'm going to skip over a few of these other properties.
And we're going to go down to our volumetric fog.
So again, we've seen the checkbox,
which just simply enables the volumetric fog.
Scattering distribution, now this
is a good one if you highlight over it.
This essentially just says in the camera frustum
where that fog is going to be visible.
So I'm going to take this all the way up to 0.9,
just to show as an example.
Kind of zoom over here where we've got some thick density.
And if I start adjusting our camera, you'll notice that,
and this may be visible on the recording,
but essentially where the fog is viewed.
Now there are situations where, again,
if we think about volumetric fog
as it is in the real world based on science,
there's just particulate in the air reacting with the light.
So if you're outside and it's a nice foggy overcast day,
you're typically going to see that light permeate
through it.
So on scattering distribution, so if I highlight over this,
you will see a distribution value of 0
scatters equally in all directions,
while 0.9 scatters predominantly in the light direction.
So in order to have visible volumetric fog light
cast from the side, which is essentially
where our camera is aimed right now, you'll be closer to 0.
So if I set this closer to 0, you'll
see that that intensity stays pretty much the same
throughout.
So again, we'll take this up to 0.9.
And again, this may be a little difficult to see,
but if I'm facing my light, you'll
see I get full intensity.
But as I kind of zoom around, you'll see that it works.
Just keep that in mind, 0.2 is a good value.
And then I'm going to adjust the albedo.
Again, I recommend just playing with these.
We'll do something like hot pink.
You'll notice that this is slightly different,
that this is just the main fog color.
Now, because we are using Lumen, it does contribute a little bit
within the scene, but it is a slightly different result
than our sky atmosphere contribution and our fog
in scattering color.
So just be careful with that.
Again, if you want some artistic effects, feel free to.
All right, so next one we're going
to look at is extinction scale.
So if I take this up to something like 10,
again, we're going to start getting some artifacts in here
just because, again, we're at a very performance size.
So you're starting to see the volumetric fog, kind
of the grid calculations.
But what this is going to do with the extinction scale
is just up the contribution of the volumetric fog
from our lights.
So default value of 1 is good.
Now, pro tip on this one, I do recommend
with your extinction scale, I would
start with 1 on your exponential height fog
because we can individually control fog contributions
on our light actors.
So for example, if I select our directional light here,
and what I'm looking for is volumetric scattering intensity.
So if I take this to something like 0.1,
you'll see that we still have our overall fog,
but the god rays, so the crepuscular rays
that are coming here, if you're in scientific,
you'll see that it's lessened.
And I can control this per light actor,
as opposed to, if I jump back over
to our exponential height fog, if I
were to adjust the extinction scale,
this will do it globally.
So just be careful.
View distance and start distance, again, this
is a parameter to help control the artistic effects
because there are situations where it may be too intense
or you may not want to see it as far as a certain
distance.
So you can adjust these, but for now, we
will keep them as is.
All right, a couple other settings
that you may want to look into, in particular
deals with crepuscular rays, also known as god rays.
So to enable your god rays and or just some
of the settings, we simply need
to go to the light source, which in this case
will be our directional light.
And if we scroll down, you see
that we have light shafts, light shaft occlusion,
and light shaft bloom.
So if I just check light shaft occlusion,
you'll notice that things kind of die down a little bit.
Now, to help showcase this on the video,
I'm just going to go to my exponential height fog.
I'm just going to take my extinction scale
and just increase it to something like 5.
Just so again, it's just overly pronounced in our scene
so we can kind of see what's happening
with our directional light.
All right, so go back to our directional light.
And again, I'll scroll down.
I'll uncheck light shaft occlusion and then check it.
And so what you'll notice is that now we're
starting to take into calculations
our shadow casting objects and where shadows are being casted.
And we are occluding the exponential height fog
information from that light source.
So if I go back to our scene, just
hold Control-L and adjust this so you can kind of see.
I'm going to try to get some to peek through here.
So if I uncheck it, in particular,
pay attention to these areas kind of hovering over here
with my mouse where we have a lot of our fog
permutation in here.
So we see a lot of the fog in our scene.
We can see our light.
So if I check this, you'll see that now it's
basically occluding that information.
And it's only showing this fog effect in the areas
where the light is present.
Now, something to take note here.
So the occlusion mass darkness,
think about this kind of like a opacity slider.
Now, it's not opacity.
But if I were to take the occlusion mass darkness all
the way up to 1, and if I uncheck light shaft occlusion,
you'll notice that nothing changes in the scene.
So this is how you can individually control
or artistically control how much of that fog is occluded.
So if I go to something like 0, you
see that it only shows in areas
where the light is there versus 0.05, we get a little bit.
So again, from an artistic perspective,
if you felt like, hey, this is a really foggy scene,
it shouldn't be this clear in my shadows,
well, just take your occlusion mass darkness up.
And you see we can add some of that back to our scene.
All right, so let's go back down here.
The other thing that we can do is our light shaft bloom.
So if I check this, we'll probably
get something that blows out quite heavily
and very similar to other bloom properties,
bloom scale and threshold.
So if I take the threshold up all the way,
may not be visible because this is very, very prominent.
But bloom scale, I could do something like 0.1 or 0.01.
It's very sensitive towards the lower end of the scale here.
So if I take it like 0.2, and you say ramp it up,
it's not a whole lot of effect outside
of just getting blown out.
But if you're really trying to lessen this,
do something like 0.01.
I'll uncheck this, check it on.
And you see we just get some nice extra, essentially
what this is mimicking right particulate in the air,
light is bouncing off of it.
They're kind of like mini bounce cards.
So that light is bouncing off of that particulate
and going back into our scene.
So this adds a nice little touch of realism.
But again, the default values may be a little too bright
for you, so feel free to adjust that.
And then of course, in tandem with that
is the bloom threshold.
So this is just something where you can control
where that bloom will be visible.
So we'll keep it at 4.
I'm sorry, set it back to 0.
And then bloom max brightness, again, this
is just something we can adjust.
Similar in nature to bloom scale,
you'll see that bloom max brightness,
the slider is very sensitive.
We kind of go from 15, 20 to 100 all of a sudden.
Again, you can click in here, do something like 50,
or you can drag this as well.
And then we've got bloom tint, which is just again another
layer of artistic control.
So I could do something like our hot pink.
And you'll notice that this only affects bloom, not
the actual volumetric itself, or the fog color,
or the end scattering color.
This is specifically just for the bloom.
Reset that.
All right, so that should cover the basics
of editing our volumetric fog.
Hopefully, you understand the parameters and the properties
that you would adjust to achieve the artistic effect
that you're looking for.
So before we jump into our next video,
I'm going to do this off camera.
I'm just going to reset some of these settings
just to get it back to a default state,
as opposed to our overly blown out, overly artistic state.
So you'll see the magic behind the scenes.
And then we'll go to the next module in this course.
In the next video, we'll discuss
how to optimize your volumetrics
and cover various CVARs that will
allow you to increase or decrease
fidelity over performance.